Now let's look at the relationships
between SMT and cache performance.
The cache of the core,
is shared by all of the SMT threads
that are currently active on for
example, if you have 2 SMT then the
cache is shared by both of the threads.
That gives us some good and
some bad properties.
The good property Is that we get
fast data sharing among the threads.
When Thread 0 stores something, and
then Thread 1 wants to read it,
it gets to get a cache shared.
So any communication between these
threads that happens within a short span
of time like we store and
then we quickly load in another thread,
will go through the cache and
have really,
really good performance because the load
here will always be a cache hit,
assuming that the store
happened recently.
So the communication now no
longer goes through shared memory
because we have a cache.
The communication tends to
go through just the cache.
But when we have an SMT processor,
the cache capacity that we have and
its associativity is shared
by all of the threads.
So if the working set of thread
0 plus the working set of
thread 1 minus the part of the working
set that they have in common,
which will be counted
twice if we did this,
exceeds the data size,
we get what is called cache trashing.
Pretty much the data no
longer fits in the cache, and
we get a lot of cache misses.
If each of the working sets would fit
individually in the data cache size,
then the performance
of the SMT can be and
usually is significantly worse than
doing the threads one at a time.
So we were assuming that when we did
SMT that we will get some benefits from
using resources that would otherwise be
underutilized like the issue slots and
the reservation stations and so on.
But that assumes we are getting
similar cash performance.
However, if the cash
has a given size and
threads are written to fit in that cash,
then running two such threads
if they don't share enough data,
might exceed the cash size in which case
suddenly we have a lot more misses
then we expected and we make payback.
In cache misses a lot more than
we gain by overlapping execution
in the SMT fashion.